c'est notre seule chance
on n'a pas le choix
[Musique]
on a besoin de kong
le monde en a besoin
pour empêcher ce qui se prépare
et cette fillette est la seule avec
qu'il accepte de communiquer
je savais qu'il s'était projet
elles étaient seulement alors
j'ai promis de la protéger
et je crois que cette façon
quand même chose
[Musique]
ccoty là
dangereux
me dis là s'en prend à tout le monde et
on ignore pourquoi
que change le provoque mais aussi parce
que c'est je pense que les chances sont
réelles
il y à une guerre dont ils sont les
derniers survivants
qui s'incline deux banques et les
constats
kong ne s'incline devant personne
[Musique]